[Música]
soy la que se acaba de bajar del
escenario que venía a hablar del fracaso
les dije que una parte de mí quería
salir corriendo y el que avisa no
traiciona salí corriendo
voy a empezar de nuevo mi charla para
para que puedan disfrutar porque sé que
a muchos les va a venir bien lo que
tengo para contarles
les decía hace más o menos un mes tenía
un presentimiento horrible de que iba a
hacer el ridículo
ahí me dieron
y me repetía que era una muy mala idea
de hecho planea escribir un mail muy
convincente diciendo que no podía tener
el compromiso que
total la pandemia nos daba excusas para
todos
alguien me recordó me dijo que me
acordara porque había empezado porque
tenía tantas ganas de hacer esto y por
eso estoy acá de nube o intentando
la realidad es que soy emprendedora
serial tuve muchos emprendimientos y a
pesar de que las sillas eran buenas y
los proyectos eran viables todos fueron
un fracaso y créanme que lo intentaba de
charlas ted leí posteos blogs libros
bibliografía de marketing y aún así
todos mis emprendimientos seguían
fracasando cuando yo estaba por bajar
los brazos
pensé que ya iba a abandonar mis sueños
me encontré con una frase polémica
los creadores de tu propio fracaso
y le voy a decir de nuevo los creadores
de tu propio fracaso imaginen me yo que
estoy acá poniendo el pecho en mi
emprendimiento diez dos horas por día
siendo administrativa operativa
secretaria así y de mi proyecto yo voy a
ser creador es mi propio fracaso alguien
más piensa que esto es cualquier cosa
alguien levanten la mano sí
es cualquiera qué tipo de broma es ésta
así que seré todo
voy a leer algo que me motive más pero
como todas las frases que a uno le mueve
un poco el piso
volvió a aparecer una y otra vez como
dándome la oportunidad de romper un poco
mis esquemas o al menos replantearme los
que tenía en la semana siguiente estuve
atenta presta atención a las tareas que
emplazaba a mis dudas a los momentos en
los que valía mi responsabilidad
y buscaba una de esas frases reveladoras
pero lo que encontré fue una voz adentro
mío que me repetía
escenarios terribles y miedos ridículos
que me recordaba cuáles eran mis puntos
débiles
que me iban a decir que no que me bajé
del escenario que
que si lograba conseguir todos esos esos
trabajos no iba a llegar a terminar los
que quieren me creía que era que espera
tener una mejor idea y muchas muchas
otras cosas más
entonces
lo más loco de esa voz no era lo que
decía ni lo ridículo de los miedos sino
lo incorporada que tenía esa voz que
nunca la había notado pero pensemos
juntos
somos todos creadores de nuestro propio
fracaso como puede haber gente que sí
logre el éxito digo todos queremos ser
creadores
todos queremos ser héroes de nuestra
propia historia
se está poniendo fresco
entonces lo que yo quería saber acá era
por qué y cómo y cómo hackear esta
realidad para ser protagonista y
creadora al menos de mis propios
resultados lo que yo quería era una
fórmula una fórmula de modo de quitarle
un poco esta incertidumbre al éxito y al
fracaso y acá es donde las frases
reveladoras empieza a tener sentido
entonces mi conclusión se de más o menos
así mis resultados son la suma de saber
que quiero sumado con tomar decisiones y
todo eso potenciado por las excusas
día a día lo más fácil de reconocer son
estas excusas estos
motivos que tienen una apariencia super
razonable y nos alejan de lo que tenemos
que tener terminado
merecen nuestra atención porque algo nos
están queriendo contar algo tenemos que
aprender de eso desataría que emplazamos
de eso que no terminamos de ese cliente
al que nos llamamos
si ustedes no tuvieran todas esas
excusas que sería lo próximo que
tendrían que hacer si no tuvieran todas
esas excusas quién se animarían hacer y
sacando las excusas del lado nos queda
un combo mortal de dos variables
la primera es saber que quiero tener una
idea clara del éxito
qué implica si coincide con la vida que
quiero tener
y la segunda es tomar decisiones
a tomar decisiones no decidir no cortar
el bacalao nos pone una distancia enorme
entre dónde estamos y dónde queremos
estar
esto nos deja en un lugar como de
inacción en una zona de confort alejados
de una vida activa donde vamos creando
nuestro futuro decisión a decisión y lo
cierto
lo cierto es que si no sabemos que
queremos y no tomamos decisiones acordes
somos creadores de nuestro propio
fracaso
yo dije listo no tenemos futuro no
tenemos más nada para hacer se puede
hacer algo
se puede hacer algo
pero lo primero que hay que hacer es
mirar hacia adentro vamos de nuevo con
la misma ecuación que quiero más tomar
decisiones y todo esto potenciado por
las excusas
lo primero es saber que quiero y
perseguir un objetivo que sea auténtico
para mí misma
a veces perseguimos objetivos que tienen
que ver con otros objetivos que tienen
que ver con alguien a quien admiramos
que nos gusta lo que hace pero no le
estamos poniendo nuestra propia impronta
queremos ser otros y esos ya sabemos que
no funciona
entonces lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es
permitirnos ser nosotros mismos y si nos
permitimos ser nosotros mismos y salimos
a mostrarnos al mundo hoy estoy acá por
segunda vez dando una charla térek
y si nos mostramos al mundo tal como
somos recién ahí empieza la magia
recién ahí pero si no nos mostramos y
nos quedamos en el miedo que nos lleva a
la inacción y se potencia con las
excusas para arruinarnos la vida
entonces lo primero que hay que hacer es
darse permiso de ser uno mismo y acá
tenemos que entender algo los miedos y
las excusas tienen forma de un bichito
que habla perfecto español y vive
adentro de su oído bien bien adentro
es una voz que va a convivir con
nosotros toda la vida y es estrella de
series como el síndrome del impostor tu
papel de víctima y la profecía
autocumplida
esta voz está decidida a quedarse porque
es parte de uno mismo y es sabio
aprender a reconocer cuando uno está
atendiendo a esta voz de miedos a
estados cobardes y cuando uno está
haciendo razonable porque les prometo
que son dos cosas completamente
distintas
son pensamientos saboteadores que te
revuelven el estómago y te alejan de
todas las oportunidades más grosas de la
vida pero a esta ecuación le hace falta
algo y es que muchas veces creamos
sistemas creamos
condiciones que nos inhabilitan a
conseguir lo que verdaderamente ya
dijimos que queríamos creamos servicios
muy difíciles de explicar por ende pasar
un presupuesto es una tarea imposible
creamos productos que requieren nuestra
dedicación exclusiva y son indelegables
por ende no vamos a crecer en ventas nos
proponemos tener más cosas terminadas en
un día y hacemos listas imposibles de
terminar alguien fan de las listas por
acá si levanten la mano
culpable primera
qué ridículo no nos creamos emprendemos
para buscar la libertad y nos la
condición amos a nosotros mismos nos
impedimos conseguirlas
suena tan ridículo cuando le echamos luz
que parece algo completamente absurdo y
por eso es tan importante
reconocerlo
antes de fracasar como víctimas de
nuestro propio proyecto
entonces vamos a pasar en limpio nuestra
nuestra ecuación
actuó sabiendo que quiero poniendo mi
propia impronta aunque esa idea de éxito
cambio a través del tiempo tomo
decisiones no me quedo esperando un
golpe de suerte
y como las excusas no las voy a poder
erradicar
por lo menos puedo elegir actuar a pesar
de las excusas
y si además me muevo con sistemas que
jueguen a mi favor por lo menos el
camino va a ser más sano y no va a ser
un camino lleno de mis propios
obstáculos desde que descubrí esto ayudó
a mujeres emprendedoras
descubrir esta fórmula a interpretar sus
excusas a tomar mejores decisiones
armar sistemas que jueguen a favor de su
proyecto y volviendo a nuestra frase
original no somos creadores de nuestro
fracaso no somos creadoras de nuestro
éxito sino que somos seres creadores y
como seres creadores podemos crear la
vida que deseamos para crear algo en que
creer